hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week
on the supernatural finale the mother of
all cliffhangers happen and as crazy as
it is to think I think season 10 is
gonna be one of the most interesting the
show has ever had Metatron even gave us
one of the best ideas for a new
Supernatural spin-off that I've heard in
a long time if you're just finding me
for the first time I do videos for all
kinds of awesome sci-fi and fantasy that
I really love like supernatural Game of
Thrones Marvel be sure to subscribe to
get everything and feel free to leave me
any suggestions for bonus videos you
want to see me do for Team Winchester
during the hiatus so time to get
Winchester that's not a sex thing by the
way careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet but
let's start with top five moments and
then I'll do my review as well as talk
about Season ten just a little bit but
here we go
number five Metatron becomes the world's
biggest YouTube star ahead of PewDiePie
it's actually a pretty ingenious plan if
you wanted people to start thinking you
were god you'd have to use some sort of
social media platform to reach as many
eyeballs as quickly as possible and
YouTube is the world's biggest social
media platform people just forget that
because it's video
I always thought angels needed human
souls to pick out more powerful like
whenever Castiel became God he didn't
really literally become God he just
became so powerful he was like God and
the same is true for Metatron he's just
tapping into the energy of the angel
tablet that's why he made that strange
reference whenever he was punching
Dean's lights out he was talking about
being powered by the Word of God that
tablet was literally powering him versus
Dean being powered by the blade
obviously the word God's gonna be more
powerful because it's literally the
words of creation I love the idea that
he was storing it inside of his
typewriter I'm guessing he was just
translating it into readable words and
that was the story that he is writing
the best story ever that he kept talking
about if you remember he spent a lot of
time the season talking to Castiel about
how the best writers rip all their
material off so I guess he's kind of
ripping God off whenever he's writing
his story because the tablet are God's
words he's still alive anyways so
hopefully in season 10 we'll learn more
about what that story he was writing was
gonna be whatever his ending was it's
almost like george RR martin teasing out
bits of winds of winter on his blog
maybe that's what Metatron is gonna do
in season 10 he's gonna tease out his
story number 4
Castiel uses his knowledge of pop cold
to defeat Metatron getting the villain
to monologue why you secretly broadcast
him to the whole school is an oldie but
a goodie
when Metatron told Castiel he should
have read more he was forgetting that he
implanted the sum total of all
pop-culture that it existed in his brain
remember Metatron basically copy and
pasted his brain into Castiel and he'd
seen basically every movie that's ever
been made every book that's ever been
written
so now Castiel has all that knowledge
too so in a way Metatron kind of
defeated himself
I don't think Castiel would have thought
to do that otherwise and now that he's
defeated them Cass tells The Reluctant
leader again whenever Hannah asked him
about his grace I actually thought he
was gonna go borrow Dean to heal himself
like gadreel did at the beginning of the
season I'll talk more about Castiel on
Season ten after my review but one of
the funniest are even best takeaways
from this whole scene was is that
Castiel essentially broke the most
powerful weapon in the universe to save
one person Dean
I'm sure all the destiel shippers out
there said just exploded whenever he
said that number three Crowley is
getting restless in Hell this all ties
into that speech in the diner where he
gets all existential on Dean and makes
him wonder if there's anything more for
him beyond hunting now that we've seen
the whole episode I kind of think he was
foreshadowing Dean becoming a demon like
Crowley himself was also getting tired
of the daily grind and was just waiting
for Dean to die so that the mark would
resurrect him as a demon and they can go
on new adventures together as a pair of
demons like Crowley thought he'd
replaced Sam in Dean's life as much as
Sam made fun of Dean for his Crowley
bromance I think that Crowley really
does enjoy his time with Dean for all
the Batman fans out there Rachael ghoul
actually had this really cool comic book
line once where he said memory is the
first casualty of immortality well I
guess excitement is the second because
Crowley seems like he's really getting
bored
Dean turning is like the best thing that
could have ever happened to him it
creates its own unique set of problems
for Crowley that is but I'll talk about
that after my review number two Dean
dies I always knew one of them would
sacrifice themselves at the end of the
season and given last year it was Sam's
turn it only makes sense that Dean gets
his wish and dies this season well not
exactly we won't really know what his
reaction to being a demon is till
episode
of season 10 but up to that point I
think Dean was just happy to be rid of
his blade addiction like he was happy at
the idea of solving his problems by
dying you guys can let me know what you
thought of the drug addicts storyline
it's kind of been done a little bit on
supernatural so it's not something new
but I like the idea that the drugs or
the blade never lets you go for real
like you never stop being an addict so
even though Dean's a demon he'll still
have that addiction he'll just have a
little bit more power to control it
given those last couple of moments I
think we can surmise the Dean will not
be able to die for real until he passes
the mark on to someone else and my
number one moment
no surprise here Dean becomes a demon of
all the possible resolutions to this
season this was one of the best I can't
wait to see Dean embrace some of his
more destructive tendencies being that
he's a demon he'll still have his old
personality remember think about Cain he
had the mark and when we first met him
he seemed pretty normal so I'm expecting
Dean to still tell the same jokes and
still go out for burgers and women he'll
just have some demon urges on top of all
those other vices the real question
though now is is how can Sam and Castiel
fix him or at least bring him into
heaven if that's even possible I think
it is but I think a lot of its going to
have to do with the way Castiel fixes
heaven and repairing the tablet I think
the tablets gonna be part of it too so
maybe that means that we'll bring Kevin
back because only a prophet can fix the
tablet so I'm really interested to see
what ends up happening but now it's your
turn let me know in the comments below
what was your favorite moment and do you
think that they'll be able to save Dean
or will he just spend the rest of
eternity as a demon wouldn't that be a
crazy way for them to end the series
with Sam becoming the vessel for an
angel and living forever in heaven and
Dean living forever in hell as a demon I
don't actually think that's what's gonna
happen but it's funny to think about it
that way but since there were so many
awesome one-liners here's a few of my
favorites from the episode the best was
probably Metatron saying winning a
People's Choice Award not quite the real
thing it was just a burn against Jensen
Ackles and Jared Padalecki
who have both won People's Choice Awards
but never an Emmy
although supernatural as a series has
been nominated for an Emmy twice then
there was Dean saying hell isn't
complicated Game of Thrones and shower
sex are complicated everyone
staff just must really like Game of
Thrones I've heard more references to
that show than any other on supernatural
this season it's almost like every
episode there's a game of Thrones
reference then there was Crowley saying
I guess I've been Winchester that
totally sounds like a sex act and I
cannot wait for tumblr to just run with
it then Metatron when he said they love
me they really love me in case you
didn't know Sally Field said that line
after winning back-to-back Oscars for
movies that she had done a long long
time ago like way back in the 70s
then Metatron made a reference to locked
up abroad heaven edition it's a
reference to a TV series called an Idiot
Abroad it's a comedy travel show where
Ricky Gervais Stephen Merchant and
Warwick Davis send this really dumb
person to travel around visiting places
in being silly that show is a parody
itself so Metatron is parodying a parody
and that is why I totally love
Supernatural overall just comparing
supernatural to itself in previous
finales I have to say this is definitely
one of my top three I'll say that season
5 is still my all-time favorite finale
just because that was meant to be a true
series finale like it was meant to be
the end of the show they didn't know
they were picked up for season six until
after they shot it so it was like a
real-deal ending but you really have to
look at Supernatural a little
differently than you do other shows
because it has been going on for almost
10 years which is just amazing
especially that it's sustained its
popularity to that end we really have to
give credit to the characters for being
so strong this year my new favorite is
obviously Ben Curtis Armstrong as
Metatron he actually did this interview
with Chris Hardwick on his Nerdist
podcast where he said he still cannot
get cast in a pilot to save his life but
on a show like Supernatural he can
really prove how awesome he can be is
this you know ridiculous Metatron
villain he really did make for one of my
favorite all-time supernatural villains
and because the writers used the conceit
of Metatron being the scribe of God in
writing the greatest story ever written
it gave him the opportunity to just go
nuts with pop culture jokes which also
became a backdoor to change Castiel on a
fundamental level so like now Castiel
gets everyone's jokes even though he's
not a TV junkie his brain just contains
all that knowledge I wasn't quite as
happy with Sam's arc this season as I
was with Dean in the Mark of Cain but he
has all of next year to redeem himself
as
as it can be sometimes I totally think
supernatural earns all of its moments
like the ridiculousness all comes from a
very logical place inside the universe
it's created for itself so there were
never really any plot twists or
character arcs I felt were out of place
but here's what we need to talk a little
bit about season 10 Castiel in heaven
and Dean as a demon so Castiel has to
finish fixing heaven because even though
he knows where the entrance is there's
still a bunch of wayward angels on earth
and I think it's going to involve
repairing the tablet they can be
repaired the tablets but only by the
Prophet meant to read them which means
Castiel will probably still need
Metatron's help who was currently
rotting in Heaven's prison then there's
Dean and Crowley Dean is a demon now he
still has the Mark of Cain and the first
blade so he'll have a little bit more
power over his urges to kill but he'll
still be a threat to Crowley I like the
idea that Dean might play for the throne
of Hell by using the first blade on
Crowley but I do not see the series
ending with Dean becoming the King of
Hell that is just an awesome fantasy
that I will let tumblr explore what I do
expect though is that the brothers will
be reunited they'll be like an
interesting twist though I'm really
interested to see which direction they
take it I don't expect it to be all
mopped up nice and neat but I do think
the Castiel will have his grace restored
eventually I don't want to make too many
predictions before they start teasing
out actual details for season 10
episodes but I'll bet they'll drop some
huge bombs at Comic Con this summer so
I'll be sure to do another video
whenever we get more real info in
related news if there's any team
Winchester bonus videos you guys want me
to do in the off season just let me know
in the comments
normally Tuesday's are gonna be like
Star Wars Marvel video days be sure to
subscribe to get everything
but right now you can click here for all
my other supernatural videos this season
and you can click here for the brand-new
guardians of the galaxy trailer that
movie is gonna be ridiculous and amazing
so thank you so much you guys I'll see
you tomorrow
you've just been Winchester